hey guys its up we're gonna be shooting
a skateboarding video today in order to
pull this off
cut the scarlet slim down a little bit
excite Andale off and it's a little more
compact opportunity popping this better
you off and we run with a little battery
in the side handle for the super sweet
shots oh you might notice I'm wearing
Healy's today so I can get a sweet
moving skateboard shot with the camera
flying along so we'll see how it goes so
go into some sort of flatland combo
manually flips manual flips etc and
we'll just - I'll do no effects first or
just - like editing tricks and we'll
call you try to do a couple effects
setups and then we'll move into drones
and we'll stay in home but for that for
now
we're gonna show off some cool
skateboarding tricks
hopefully trick people into believing
that Christian is actually the best
skateboarder in the world
telephoto wide back way power low angle
kind of just showing like just nice
frame wind is blowing it just literally
just comes in the frame manualing from
frame ready and starts going and you see
them approach that in manual and we see
them start to do the ollie and then any
always out of flat and we'll just cut on
the ollie of his man he's successfully
ollied it slow man he's like he'll ollie
up on to that you can do a trick maybe
onto it so I'm gonna man you and that's
what you should do come off it
then that's that's literally low
wide-angle right next to him he we shot
like landing always going on it on it
and then he jumps off actually let's put
out this on here all you got to do is
you're gonna stop down instead of a
fourteen-year to be more like a 10 or 11
Wow
alright so here we are at lunchtime we
have like two shots shot but it's okay
because there's no effects in the shots
meaning this shots are done once they're
in the camera anyways here's us up so
we're trying to do tricks we haven't
really shot a lot of skateboard videos
before we haven't got any skateboard
videos before so we're kind of figuring
out as we go a lot of skateboarding
going on a lot more skateboard and about
to go down I really thought I was
getting the deal here
given the fact that I was given a six
ounce cherry squeeze bot freeze
turns out tastes like I'm eating
chemicals with just enough hint of
cherry to make me want to keep me well
all in all pretty big disappointment now
for this video we want to do some
impossibly long complex skateboard
combos in this shot for example you see
us doing a grind where Chris pulls off
three tricks in a row that would
probably be impossible to do in real
life so what we did is recorded him on a
green screen doing the tricks
individually and I took him cut him out
and actually strung together the tricks
so looked like it was one long unbroken
take then we took the shot motion
tracked it and added Chris as an element
onto the railing a touch of shadow and
the piece looks completely finished
pretty tricky son so basically he's got
a kickflip in the hole cameras can vote
and so from our perspective we're just
gonna see the board be perfectly still
in the world this kid has been around it
this is where you lose a GoPro just
watch well in it I'm calling it alright
let's see if this thing can live up to
the challenge I could just keep taping
it more but it's not really gonna be any
more effective the first one definitely
hurt I landed right on my wrist and I
should be wearing wrist guards but I'm
not let's do heavens
[Applause]
yeah oh my god that's it holy crap
that's so cool dude that's so cool you
always talk about getting those random
GoPro shots and videos and never you
haven't there of you and then Oh
have three boards ha ha I thought that's
the only way to differ
alright first day we pretty good um I
guess city chords big experiment so we
didn't si get a ton of stuff done we did
get a couple cool sequences got a couple
of little shots I main thing I think we
got out of this first day of shooting is
really just experimenting and kind of
getting a grasp on kind of just
skateboarding in general because Nikko
myself don't don't know how to
skateboard like this so it's kind of a
very new thing just to conceptualize and
Frank plan for so yeah I mean the
biggest challenge is we're trying to do
basically a Tony Hawk pro skater
combination so every trick needs to be
connected by a manual and to do a trick
land in the manual and do a trick out of
a manual it's really hard um so we're
doing our best to work with that and
work around it and put together it's
something that's cohesive
[Music]